back up my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching
city sidewalks
I smell love hummus but I'm a bum bum
hummus huh yeah I brought that time of
season smell your hands huh smells of
love leak with daring you built the
animals remember that I don't city
sidewalks bah rum pum pum what you guys
favorite Christmas songs huh
silent night that's the worst one yeah
that one makes me feel so lonely doing a
by myself Kevin in home alone when he's
by himself eating and that man is tucked
petting those birds boo that bird man
yeah that broom he was a girl with you
know the pigeon [ __ ] yeah call girl in
the new when it's a girl I guess no no
the one you talking about home alone to
New York City and Kevin referred to as
the pigeon [ __ ] damn did he really yeah
how's his only friend ain't it I think
you got a bootleg version I might owe
this one did walk by the screen Kevin
the worst parents ever
yeah forgotten what twice what's uh do
they have a traditional Vietnamese
Christmas song do you know no Christmas
isn't that big hmm
what is a big holiday there uh Chinese
New Year oh wow which we just called
Vietnamese new year
or new year and when is that it changes
from every I think four years it's on a
February but it's usually sometime in
January I'm using based on the lunar
calendar and they do is everybody enjoy
it or is it yeah it's the best time you
gamble you drink you eat you hang out
with your family if you're not married
you get money oh wow yeah you started
giving money to people in your family
after you've been married so as long as
you're not
married you just keep receiving money
keep them rolling in that mont priced
and single for quite some time my family
catch that bag yeah yeah your dad thank
you bankroll PJ yeah yes I know yes well
happy uh Merry Christmas g-man Merry
Christmas as the as the new PC cultures
Happy Holidays
yeah and I don't say that nice a Merry
Christmas - Merry Christmas
that's what I say Derek yeah what are
you would you like the black you were
doing the Seinfeld interlude dude I like
your Christmas sweater thanks man you
got it for me
I knew you'd like it and yours looks
good man it's you on the front it's me
reaching out for help to get on a diet
dude you look like my drunk aunt though
you look fresh dude look freshest party
oh yeah put me under the mistletoe dude
hell yeah I'm that lesbian aunt that's
always lurking under the mistletoe you
know always giving out got your pool
stick you know the scarf yeah thanks
Marge that lesbian aunts always crazy
always eat you something Fred dog you'd
even have a dog that shitty yep oh
thanks for the model of the Subaru
Outback I'm sure I'll play with this
thank you
oh that's a wild one man and we have
gifts here today - yos we got everybody
brought in something for the white
elephant yeah so much cream white
elephant it's random you don't know what
you're gonna keep is that how it works
dude whoever gets my gift enjoy really
enjoy it so I'm gonna say we just spend
under $20 we did yeah oh good now mine's
the blue on the front okay
and so they it's covered by chips
because I don't want you to see inside
oh really
but the crazy part is you ate some of
those chips on the way most of them so
you can kind of see what's in there just
don't look and we got Nick and chin in -
how you guys doing that is that chin
dressed as Santa Wow oh wow man did you
steal that from Tim Allen
you look fantastic yeah dude you look
like the Chinese New Year oh yeah dude
happy new year and Nick looks like if
they did bad Santa for with a Billy Bob
Thornton as an elf my favorite part of
that sentence was eating that salad
he's just a royal [ __ ] do you mind if my
kiddies yeah Nick looks like he would be
in a million dollar baby you know didn't
that Billy Bob thorn in that Restless
movies yeah we watched Million Dollar
Baby on Christmas Eve together as a
family
dude Batman Returns as a Christmas movie
great Christmas movie is it
I think it's Christmas movie greatest
Christmas movie all-time family man with
Nicolas Cage have you seen it
oh that's so good dude how about when
they're at the mall and he goes to get
that fancy suit she's like what the [ __ ]
we can't afford this yeah this guy need
this suit like fine get it [ __ ] yeah mmm
movies heartfelt and he chased her down
in the air pop her in the airport yeah
he's like we got have a house in Jersey
we have house interns we have two kids -
Kenny and Josh Josh yeah that's right
and it's not ours but in 227 more
payments it will be ours hey how about
when they're getting all hot and heavy
and she's all tell me what I want to
hear because you're so [ __ ] hot baby
she's like real nice I said the wrong
thing yeah and then she glows up the
stairs by herself
yeah did you have the one where remember
the next-door neighbor is always trying
to [ __ ] him she's bad as [ __ ] and
me pivens his boy in there yeah and he's
like dude you can't they can't [ __ ] her
it was the perfect relationship
yeah Jay he's like I'm definitely going
to yeah did you have the bootleg version
when he actually goes and [ __ ] her
there's not that version yeah I had that
one dude he really drives it home oh
yeah yeah oh my god it really made me
think this is differently about the film
now I loved that film but I loved it too
I'm not gonna see that version and I am
gonna watch it this year of my family
what are you guys gonna watch yeah over
and over and over dawg every time you
said like you're feeling better than
last week me a little better are you
alive
yeah better how was la jolla good great
yeah every club thanks for coming
favorite club bastard
what was it any crazy people come out or
what was the vibe I mean San Diego
people Republican they're rich but they
gonna party yeah they're all white
people they come to [ __ ] party I
always say don't go out after dark in
San Diego unless you're looking for a
fight
really oh dude military college boys and
fighters yeah mix that in that's
downtime yeah that's down there over
them by the beach baby baby people's a
beach pacific beach yeah i love it now
high isn't it you can't find anything
you can't even find a breeze out after
probably about 7:45 p.m.
notice the subs up there shrubs I could
live there man if I'd have to be in LA
there 100% it's relaxing in there mm-hmm
from San Diego Oklahoma I'm Oklahoma
this weekend are you Oklahoma and Tulsa
after Christmas yeah bro Wow
so let's pay for these goddamn toys you
feel me you working hard what kind of
toll would you get your kid watching yet
lining up mercedes-benz I'm a benz and
the payments are not cheap what you get
here the newborns his own stem cells
I see I'm a time-sharing table oh wow
well and be interesting what's good
though we don't want to get into these
white elephants or what do we do want to
say that for the end that's what we
added we had to say for the end we do
hmm it's up it's up to you guys yeah you
say for them that's fine I can't thank
man my brains tired tired yeah all day
is a gift your bro I know what is how
about Jews eight days of this Oh
how they do it eight crazy nights
shutdown eight crazy nights and what do
they do at night party or hardy every
night and you get one gift every night
now my girls Mexican so they celebrate
they do everything on Christmas Eve
oh yeah the white the white the whites
we do it Christmas morning
so it's a real conflict of interest in
this yeah is it yeah we'll do everything
on Friday night you know we like doing
in the morning actual Christmas oh yeah
we cook French toast we'd open up all
our gifts one at a time when I'm at
skins do all the girly yeah there is
just chaos
hey sue crazy furrows there's [ __ ]
tamales in your spiel yeah I'm like
chaos dude what yeah and there's like
animals and stuff too mewls sure the
manger that's what I like
what's that the manger it's where Jesus
was a baby it's like where he spent like
I some good bit of his childhood got a
camel there I was that a movie or three
dudes showed up out there brah it must
be like an episode of um oh no what's
that thing where Chris Hanson Catch a
Predator 2 gets a predator it's like the
earliest to catch a predator dude what
do you think Chris hands is doing on
Christmas not catching gifts you think
no no he didn't I do together I don't
know man somebody's getting him
something he Evers a son he has two sons
Oh does he
when I was a newscaster NBC's not give
him any gifts he hasn't actually I don't
know what he's doing I don't know he
caught a lot of bad guys I guess and
some guys that seemed okay I think semis
just got caught up some guy could happen
to anybody someone like I get it dude
trying to keep the lights on man alive
you never know if you're gonna know
somebody whenever you you know you're
out and about yeah I don't know your
timer dude listen if you want eggnog
yeah at 4:00 in the afternoon this
holiday season mmm I know somebody can
bring it to you don't call me anymore to
drop off your a grommet it it comes all
lukewarm half drink I like it I like it
especially when you ride over you let
this let the thing warm up between your
legs
oh yeah yeah I try to do
I notice that dude I can't be doing that
anymore you got to start using postmates
it's your personal food delivery grocery
delivery whatever kind of delivery
service all year round really wherever
you're craving post mates can deliver
what 24 hours a day 365 days a year even
on Christmas Post mates will bring you
what you need within an hour everything
but if I want meat or fish you name a
dude get some eggnog with a side of
Fleming know whatever you want download
the app on your Apple or Android for
free browse local restaurants and
businesses and you can track your
delivery in real time get them a deal
dude it's Christmas be cool alright I'll
cool alright I'll hit you with this deal
deal do you for a limited time post
mates is giving cats listeners $100 of
free delivery credit for your first
seven days excuse me
anything you need anytime you need it
post mates it download post mates and
save with the code Kay ATS two zero one
nine
yep that's code K 80s to zero one up for
$100 a free delivery credit for your
first seven days when you download the
post mates app anything you need anytime
you need it post made it downloaded post
mates and save with code cats two zero
one nine dude if I what do I seem like
I've been running fast or doing some
just look yeah you just look super
you're glowing
mmm-hmm you've just been glowing your
energies through the roof well it's two
reasons one I drank part of a um a glow
stick do you know that they have it uh
like there's electric crackle oh yeah
rave huh do you get it really got it
outside of a race it makes sense a used
one and dude I wouldn't say it's not
good but it's not bad but also because
I've been taking athletic green I knew
there's a secret dude yeah the one thing
health experts dieticians and athletes
and top performers agree on is that a
perfect diet that ain't real even with a
bounce healthy diet can be tough to
cover your nutritional bases through
food alone everyone's like dude what up
with the green you got to stay green bro
don't be green with them to be green
with Atletico
it's an all in one health drink
seventy-five vitamin mineral whole food
sourced ingredients make it easier for
to get the nutrition don't be run
dragging your mouth open running through
the yard and stuff or sucking on the
back
lawnmower back those days are over they
quit licking the lawnmower get the
Greenes right now athletic green living
in powder form you mix it with water it
tastes delicious and your body level up
yup get bent out on those greens bro you
won't even know who you are you won't
even know anybody yeah want to start
each day squaring away your nutritional
needs
this can help you athletic greens
dot-com /k ATS
yeah and you want you guys get a special
20 free travel packs 20 free travel
packs value at $17 with your first
purchase
that's athletic greens comp /k ATS yes
that's athletic greens comm /k a TS what
do we do here get a scent of some stuff
there we got some Christmas questions oh
yeah
this is Connor Jones from Ontario Canada
oh dude
what about Scrooge Oh Scrooge is good
and Miracle on 34th Street like hurt you
like National Lampoon's Christmas I
haven't seen oh yeah that is good is
that the one with the grandmother dies
yeah but remember you get that check if
anything see me a bonus oh yeah and he
gives them a grocery search well Clark
you know Park you're gonna be fine yeah
yep and then the uncle goes down there
and tells the guy what to do in the
treat him right oh that's what I missed
to do you know that old polish surprise
party dude [ __ ] kidnapping somebody
oh yeah that's sort of [ __ ] telling
Christmas John yeah yeah let's hear it
hold up pause it for a second posit dude
he looks identical to the bad guy from
Incredibles when the little girl grows
up he looks spot-on really yes the kid
from The Incredibles Incredibles what uh
just the movie I'm thinking launch
Able's those were nice too
never gave me enough does a child you
gotta have too
three of them scroll down to the yeah
that there is boom Wow let's see the man
again Wow good call kind of decision
very similar kind of Irish kind of like
a nighttime kind of guy it's not bad
thing you're saying like similar to him
yup it looks like a very yeah you know
what your Halloween costume is next year
this fella there you go enjoy bro yep
freebie that one's on the house city
sidewalks turning a ting ting me and my
groom they always have like that Spanish
guys like am I wrong all I got was a who
[Music]
you done that yeah man I go in and I
look nice yeah it'd be quiet tonight
some guy with things like that like now
hold down roll for the night before
Christmas and all the bells ring and we
were [ __ ] having a party boy my friend
got out of you Christmas oh dude I can't
wait I'm being Mexican next time I'm
reincarnation do you come on my house
and you just feel Mexican oh I've been
over there dude I've been in there you
were there for Thanksgiving with
Christmas we have a posole uh-huh just
soup dude there's a grown man eat soup
on Chris Eve it's kind of heartbreaking
mmm I shut up I take it yeah yeah I take
it damn dude I could see a man eating
soup on Christmas did it almost sounds
beautiful
it ain't though you know I bet hearty
meal you know I like the ham the mashed
taters you've had a Jim pecan pie
you've had enough at a pie brother yeah
you're right okay no disrespect but you
definitely see
like a guy who [ __ ] his head high
yeah right who doesn't have it all the
time but who's had it yeah I mean I do
have Pyatt in my grasp but all times
yeah I could see being having a PI
nearby okay okay let's go back to
incredible sir all right what I'm mr.
Sinha what a Pheo Santa's Little Helper
Vaughn coming at you with a Christmas
special tradition
have a Merry Christmas gang gang buzz
buzz culture culture that's cool I see
got the electric shock on his neck to
keep that [ __ ] line is he
really well you know we could have been
could have been court-ordered as well
yeah you right maybe on probation we
just don't know what a lot of these
animals are on them Dotson's yeah we got
their ass hole in your face though cuz
their little tails are like tater tots
oh they have that perky butt hole oh
really
yeah oh wow I know outlandish looking
though sounds like you've seen it I bet
you could pick one out of a police
lineup it sounds like fair you know
Merry Christmas
so he's asking what what do we do he's
asking you guys you're all sound like me
least favorite gift and family tradition
ah you start man I think or what let's
have you guys start what do you think
Garrett so we can get our thoughts
together hey I remember me and my
brother got the ps2 the day came out
like four Krait after that that [ __ ] was
heaven I was about two three years ago
yeah that was like dude I was 12 11 well
that was the best oh we could we didn't
give video games like that
yeah like we had shitty [ __ ] you know
that was like what game came with it Mel
you're solid - no I didn't bring any
games they were we got you them damn no
games no we had mr. Poston they come
with the demo games that's what I have
you
bro yeah what a clock dude it was there
but it was awesome but terrible the
PlayStation 2 yeah yeah a place hitting
2 is good I remember getting Super
Nintendo one time and we lost our minds
dude my brother's friend was over he
threw his friend through the [ __ ]
living-room window I don't know the side
yard dude super techno ball NBA Jam I'll
tell you what one kind of my mom how she
knew this guy I don't know I don't talk
about it either way he had connections
sex probably come on bro bro it's
holidays bro holidays is sexual doll
right maybe do a bad brush Anderson
anyway I didn't so he had the connection
to authentic NFL jerseys like I always
said the bootleg was like yeah I like
this Emmitt Smith won it said like Smith
with two H's okay whatever dude
anyway my mom knew this dude he was like
oh who your kid's favorite players I
think he's trying to sleep with my mom
like you said but she didn't do it but
if she honeydicked them to get these
jerseys so I got the authentic jr. sale
yeah I think the junior South San Diego
Chargers away game Jersey and my brother
got that cold I'll never forget this I
think he still has it
Deion Sanders 49ers and who's sewn in
with the patch on it
raw meat him start humping each other we
were so excited I'll never forget that
moment man either that or when I got my
pet monster bring up my pet monster this
fat-ass Monster toy similar knows the
feel but it was cool man and he came
with shame yeah similar knows the deal I
is what I have my pet monster was a big
deal dude I remember my dad got me that
vibe with that uh that my pet monster
dude let me tell you what I got I got a
didgeridoo one time somebody came
through town rolling with a couple
Dizzy's and mom [ __ ] scored one I
feel like your mom would give you a rain
stick didgeridoo if you can it's an
Australian outdoor piece Dyer one time I
did my dad got me micro
oh yeah every girl busted my parents do
they were so good
Micro Machines okay yeah dude I remember
yeah we got that didgeridoo that sound
stick baby dude go like this yeah and
then somebody [ __ ] called me up bunch
of names bunch of racial slurs because
it was they were trying to sleep and I
was outside doing it yeah yeah I
remember we had a didgeridoo in school
somebody farted did you know mess with
anymore after that
somebody needs to play that didgeridoo I
ain't happening
I try you pink I'm miss Hampton
somebody's always drunk and singing cuz
you know hell yeah do you like eggnog no
these outdoor animal like Rudolph the
Red Nose Day - no we like when necks
yeah singing Christmas songs yeah I just
love the exchange rate on any like any
time eyes on me looking for something
I'm like that's nothing man but it
sounds great yes - intruders no no we
host open sleigh looking for my prayers
laughing all the way looking for my
breath looking for my breath too much
man it's beautiful man police Navidad
all of the Spanish may kind of listeners
man damn what's next Christmas like he's
got a good year man he's got a little
lady you spend Christmas with your lady
Nick yep he's know you're not bringing
her with you you ain't there yet
Oh a month mmm dude I took my
ex-girlfriend home after like three
weeks one time oh yeah are the only time
really
how'd it go it was good she's all she's
great so yeah it was good but it was
yeah I mean it's just yeah it was great
you know so I remember one time I
remember one time the worst president
ever got my grandma she gave me a
blanket with a with a [ __ ] eagle on
it like when I was 19 she gave me a
blanket with an eagle on oh yeah she was
bending over to get the gift she farted
really yeah man big lady I'll never
forget that it's almost beautiful man
was it a cold day out anyway I mean
she's not small bro dude I'm not
blankets the 19 year old
yeah man you got to stay warm at all
ages man you should be really grateful
about that but I love hearing a senior
fart especially if it's outdoors and
it's a crisp silent kind of time if it's
snowy out and here's like a Crisp apple
but yeah yeah like somebody bitin into a
damn but Apple do you then just watch
Larry King Live I do just be fart now oh
it's that time of year man Jim what are
you doing for Christmas yeah that's the
worst beard I've ever seen family pretty
general you do a Christmas friend thing
and what about the date Jen have you
gone on the date yet
okay nice you give you a whole month of
opportunity that's good are you gonna
get our gift ooh you bad boy a breaking
stereotype
come on come on God come on who cares
man how big your penis is or is it man
dude what's up my gifts here bro will
you make it sexual my bad my bad my bad
guy can't just give a big old gift off
the bat Jenny on a warm-up rockin around
director holiday everyone's fighting
outdoors right now thank you grandma
biting flamin hot cheetos you're racist
for her dude
Boise really both of them full Mexican
Mexican then that's not your son but I
feel you dog here you wrote I love that
brah foster children I love it
support the podcast dude one thing I
can't get enough of is honey oh yeah you
want that drippy huh you don't want that
drippy on my laptop do cuz when I'm
shopping this holiday season thank God
for a honey I save so much money buying
all my stupid friends presents a man
brother drip drip your drop drop drop
drop and it's so easy and it's free
honey is a free browser extension that
automatically finds the breasts promo
codes whenever you shop online honey if
you're buying just this holiday season
then you need honey if you're not you
probably know someone who is so do them
assault and save them money and tell
them about honey honey can make sure
that you're getting the best price for
whatever you're buying honey has over
100,000 plus five-star reviews
that's a phenomenal amount it's free to
use and it installs in just two clicks
it's so easy because you're going to
check out you don't know if you got the
best deal instead of thinking oh man do
I go look at twenty other sites no you
just click on hunting and it lets you
know if you did it cheapest and correct
mommy don't call you honey get honey for
free I'd join honey calm / k 80s let's
join honey calm / k 80s
stay bent bruh our Leslie job what else
we got a little debate club from our boy
j-rod Oh
[Music]
hardcore lash is that a fringe a crowd
yeah I come to you on the behalf of the
and I bring gifts spare the lives of the
more Kathleen and it's very Oh
homosexual men there's certain guys that
get Christmas and gifts I accept your
offer care rod but I only take one
I won't take this to a higher pay
[Music]
Christmas vacation
or Christmas stoy j-rod dude let the
culture culture Merry Christmas
Wow is that Tirana
I don't know where are we both gonna be
it did is he filming that I've seen the
director of x star the eddying all that
[ __ ] he is nothing to work with
dude that's incredible yeah he's good
Wow very yeah yeah I think yeah we'll
send him something let's think of
something nice to send him well it's
Christmas we can think of right now of
what to send him some didgeridoo some
old pet monster if he's into it
Oh a no pet monster would be great that
what do you think he would like Kadim
she have you ever gotten a man a gift
before I have I think j-rod could use
like a king in the stink flannel that'd
be dope he's always wearing flannel yes
always yeah yeah we could swag him up
probably with some nice uh you know
fashion oh yeah as in - war it's got an
amazing freakin video man yeah all year
man from the beginning to the end I said
we a do something for him where are we -
we're with the March 26 are you on the
February 21st I think I'm in Red Bank
New Jersey no he's in Canada he is I'm
pretty sure Jay runs in Canada then I'm
in Toronto that's hard
I think it's Toronto because I don't
think that I remember that both of us
are both in Toronto a what 26 21st from
Toronto February 21st for you May 26 for
me that's rano gang there we go then
yeah that's amazing man well I think for
both of those movies brah at a certain
point dude
those movies bro smoked a bowl of ass no
I was John I thought we were gonna have
to argue about this it's like I love it
until I don't man Christmas story I
can't really I don't [ __ ] with it yeah
just get a little out of hot into it I
still like the one with the cousin Eddie
with the wild shoes you know with the
white boots with Tom it's Chris
Christopher Lloyd miss Christmas
vacation right yeah Christmas vacation
dude i [ __ ] with my favorite holiday
movies Jim Carrey is the Grinch
oh [ __ ] all that I like Whoville
yeah dude Tim who's bro they out here
they thought and dawg a lot of these
[ __ ] some were they caught a couple
who's where was it I think outside of
Toledo dude doing something nasty Boston
about little Cindy Lou who you know and
I think she was a foster child they
don't have a lot of backstory honor
that's the issue for me I enjoy it
though but back to Jay rods thing I
don't [ __ ] with it if I have to pay
Christmas vacation but there's been so
many better Christmas movies now yeah
dude I'd rather smoke to vape cartridges
in my cousin's but right because I think
it's just no good
eggnog off my mom's tits before I watch
those you're smoking difficult is man
dude you said you're gonna smoke bulls
they're cousins
ass instead all of his ass dude I would
never get near his bumper the lighter I
would take parts of his ass if something
happened to him and [ __ ] you know
Sparkle yeah but the bottom line is I
don't like these movies but I like Jay
run dude I like Christmas dude I like
j-rod but the movies I think I'd rather
watch elf I'd rather watch Bad Santa too
I'd rather watch family man not bad
senate i'd rather watch uh I'd rather do
a little bit of peeping timing bro cuz
people don't they don't they're inside
more this time of year so it's easy to
see them some are people are coming in
and out of the door all the time you
know it's busy yeah winner you pull up
bro you cheer up outside of a [ __ ]
window dude
Dark Knight's like much in the real
world oh you got two hours of viewing
brah legit real-world yeah bro Christmas
edition yeah I'm a solid family it's
kind of nice man make no rating some
better feet making you want something
better for myself sometimes yeah well
you can always come over my house man
thanks man I appreciate it dude come
over there and have a couple of grams of
eggnog huh
yeah dude but once you come over there
and do your imitation of Mexican singing
how that goes whatever roads a good
impersonation man I enjoy it it's
vintage Latino is what it is bro yeah
that's that bottle I gave you my wrist
there's Christmas to come home last
Christmas I helped you get in Barbados
ooh that's a Sinaloa zoo baby oh yeah
thank God I ain't going on that man
there's been a fire near it you try
pulling me into that dude I just want
the ego yeah 60% Christmas vacation mmm
and I'll stay yeah I would agree with
that two out of three and next year I'll
bet it'll be 80% Christmas vacation I
just think that that other one's
starting to go by the wayside
yeah it's not like racism yep praise God
brother cool anymore
Rocco Jerome is that boy Rocco hey
what's up guys is Rocco in Louisville
Kentucky I'm about to make a big
donation at Toys for Tots and I got a
debate club for you guys what's better
name-brand toys that she could only
afford one of or generic toys that she
could buy a whole bunch of gang gang
buzz buzz ho ho Oh tight move doing the
Lord's work giving some toys to kids man
praise God I thought you're just gonna
go in the head and use the bathroom do
it number two that's what I thought he
meant hey man about to go in this toy
store
[ __ ] who do you guys think yeah I don't
like to see that
actual toys - Merry Christmas man yeah
dude you gotta have the one legit toy
cuz we got that off-brand the generic
ones first of all when I was kid you
bring around your friends like oh you
got a micro machine nah man it's just
that small machine they don't [ __ ] with
that yeah yeah it made fun of yeah you
got to come with the real toy I think
unless it's a kid that doesn't know what
a real like what a name-brand toy is I
think as my or if a kid that's been like
living in the woods or something or have
been like a feral child then I think you
gotta go
I got a GI Greg yeah just play with it
once it's [ __ ] arm fell off you know
meanwhile the risk has got them GI Joes
doing [ __ ] line them on fire and they
stay so yet GI Greg didn't face fell off
his spectra weapon was Don't Ask Don't
Tell policy yeah you're like what he
didn't even have a knife he's comes with
this rainbow flag Navidad primero de
venise la vida Spanish person whatever
mr. white got it surrounded by a man
doesn't rub off I'm 34 you gotta get in
there man I think we're forgetting some
hits from Christmas hands man yeah which
one are we forgetting oh I know which
one which one
ah ding about jingle bell Jingle Bell
Rock no Rock another Christmas reason
that's a different song Christmas song
Derrick Google I love it right I'll
[ __ ] love this [ __ ] you know I if I
get three wishes one would be here to
get better at googling to the internet
would get faster Oh drummer boy look at
my
yeah that's always things about raping
the girl oh hold outside not Rado maybe
it's cold outside need you say more baby
it's cold outside go I don't think so
I'm really scared it's all good look at
this she's like wow I don't feel
comfortable he's off take this pill Tom
a little confused he's like I think
you're talking about the Darren Sharper
mixtape family that song he's trying to
get the lady to be at the house man it's
cold out I agree he's just trying to
warm up everyone's freaking out yeah and
look if she doesn't want to be there
she's free to leave she's just trying to
get her to mill around a little long
it's on you and she goes I'm gonna call
taxi he's all oh it's pretty busy out
there I don't you get hurt do they what
are they say in the lair in the lyrics
here I really here it goes I really
can't stay baby it's cold outside and
what's going down go away baby it's cold
outside does it say I really gotta get
going [ __ ] it's this is how I'm gonna
tell you again [ __ ] a literal
banger yeah that's a good mother will
start to worry
he's on beautiful what's your hurry
[ __ ] my father will be pacing the
floor listen [ __ ] I put the fireplace
on a roar is that what they say
yeah it's cold out Brendan hey hey then
she goes well maybe just a half drink
more yes I'll put some records online
poor she's honey dick and I'm dude cuz
she spits all this game he's like yo I'm
gonna don't put the records on she's
like yeah give me a little more zoom in
a little Derek I don't know it say they
trying to have a cigarette at one point
if she's staying in smoking man they got
then their friends the neighbors might
think maybe it's bad out there I simply
must go say what's in this drink [ __ ]
quit asking so many questions
you guys are distinguished I knew how
your eyes are like starlight now okay
that's creepy this sounds like the night
Derek locked his girlfriend in the
basement yeah yeah I have to say no no
no hey hook she goes I have to say no no
no he goes mind if I'm moving closer at
least I'm gonna say that I tried I gotta
get home baby you'll freeze out there
now this is a thing man if a woman
trying to go out and freeze do it I say
no to that I say to that woman you don't
freeze you stay here you stay here now
here's where it gets a little weird she
goes ah you're very pushy you know yes I
think I like to think of it as an
opportunist where's that at right right
in the middle oh you're [ __ ] creepy
duty goes in my creepy or am I just
trying to capitalize it that Street word
I simply must go the answer is no I
think the answer is my sister will be
suspicious all right so this dude is
this guy bro did they get his name
because this dude definitely
but demons though oh this man sounds
like a [ __ ] pervert that's huh
whatever dude whoever it is they're
obviously out there vertebra yeah we
should call Chris Hanson on the case
yeah that's the thing I think if you are
if it's really cold out take care of
yourself but don't don't no dude trying
to keep you warm
well you don't have to do a cigarette if
somebody's cold out of cigarette I'm
gonna help them now you don't need a
shot of whiskey rays God brother praise
God but also that wasn't that was
written in the 50s and 60s that's what
they dude first of all if this didn't if
this song didn't happen I bet a third of
our population went even exist
and I'm not saying it's right but I'm
just saying that that's the way it
breaks down dude
you have to be convincing if you're
gonna have sex with somebody sometimes
you really are gonna be one of these
people like oh you know what do you guys
think what do you think about this song
okay it's a little weird if you think
about it in modern-day context but I
think that's just flirting from back in
the day yeah you know
it wasn't as okay for girls to be like
yeah I want to stay yes so you gotta at
least put up a front like you're
pretending to go ya bat well back then
yeah everything had more heirs yeah back
to have you shared whiskey with the man
that's a wrap son yeah they gave you the
okay also think of Looney Tunes Pepe
LePew that was a cartoon yes I do is
raping everybody was he oh do you guys
this is a Christmas episode man you know
through my animals raping no we just
talked about how times are different you
should be grateful yeah you're right
dude I'm sorry what else we got but also
looking mad man that whole series is
about that [ __ ] pick a path dude are we
talking about it or we're not talking
about it does it matter does it not the
guys trying to make love to this lady
she don't even smoke bro I think
everybody's alright and a lot of women
were doing cigarettes back then mm-hmm
60% name-brand toys respect man yeah you
can't have all I have a Dreamcast yeah
you can't have to go you know like
sometimes you would see like the one
from Winnie the Pooh you need Teager
yeah you know girl yeah
they had TIG GA and he just [ __ ] he
didn't even have like he had like purple
kind of like it wasn't even orange it
was like purple and white and black
stripes and he had a [ __ ] chain and a
watch on yeah I remember he-man there's
a lot of he-man yeah just have that man
toy yeah they had man twitch that's two
guys holding hands like we're here it's
confusing but they both have the same
haircut yeah yeah dude I remember that
game life I remember of that board game
I got one year but operator
oh yeah operation no that's right beside
the she was scary yeah yeah operator was
the one where you told somebody next to
you in the circle a store a thing
telephone and it came all the way around
operator too though right yeah an
operator yeah then they change the
telephone but by the time I got to like
the 17th changed you realize all you're
a bunch of [ __ ] liars yeah dude yeah
if things got weird you would start it
off like trying to like something real
serious like you know like hey you know
No
and then it gets to the end and you're
like everybody gets up because a [ __ ]
gay people are fist fighting for tartar
sauce you're like yeah I was touched
often and it gets around in the end dude
I was molester Greg molested me yeah but
that gets around all you're eating is
[ __ ] sugar cookies yeah is around
it's like mom's giving that porch for
Christmas to finding you my friends do
all right Gary let's get out of here
this is the last one guys it's Katie
Mason and chase Katie big Mason in chase
beautiful fake Christmas tree or real
Christmas tree you guys let us know few
kids as beautiful man oh yeah I'm not
gonna do the only choice we had was real
trees yeah it was a real hassle to
switch when the pines start falling on I
love it and when Christmas is over and
two snake fell we can do this tree the
[ __ ] tooth but I'd like carried
outside and [ __ ] it was exhausting but
it smells fantastic yeah dude I remember
trying to climb it when I was really
young and getting I had my shirt off and
just getting SAP all over my body and
then getting like all types of like
pieces of wood no no wood construction
wrapping paper stuck on this tar on the
little tar parts and [ __ ] like the
silvina yeah being an animal tensile and
everything that's living brother it was
fun bro
I think real tree we used to lay under
the tree and [ __ ] let the SAP drip on
his brother [ __ ] was fun at night the
night before you know santa came so he
smelled real drink a little bit of that
water at the bottom do you and your
brother get that man a free fountain
instead of that [ __ ] hot pine soup
boy oh yeah it was strong dude that
barks to be don't make your neck wiggle
brother it was good stuff man
so I think either one I think what as
long as you have the spirit I don't
think it matters you know and I don't
think the kids really know if they're
real young I don't think too many people
are buying real ones anymore people
don't realize how big of a deal is to
have a real one it's more of a hassle
people are a bunch of lazy [ __ ] these
days and just get do the fake tree my
mom would always get the real and we
would get everything eat on there and
some of those things in and you weren't
even a strong enough I remember having
to hold it real tight and then my
brother would turn my [ __ ] wrist like
you like I was like a screwdriver that's
all you have to do though
yeah and them all in even he's like this
and my [ __ ] good enough that's all in
my life dude him he put the ornaments up
man getting the ornaments out my mom
always did a wonderful job with
Christmas man she really yours did two
moms do a great job with that what about
Charles mom's she's the best the whole
house is always like everything she goes
all out is there anything worth taking
the decorations down god that's it sucks
dude yeah that's for Dad
yeah so depressing I might have to hold
the ladder on my dad would [ __ ] take
the lights down yeah and you're so look
at your dad but now bad is pants on yeah
I had jeans his ass holes in your face
but I just remember it took forever also
I'm eight wait what am I out here dude
cuz you're helping out this ain't doing
[ __ ] I'm just I'm just standing on the
ladder so if you fall I eat [ __ ] too
yeah yeah dude Oh a lot of dads
surviving their sons don't make it
during Falls and you got to respect that
that's a good lookin out man
that's why you have two three four five
sons dude right back in the day had 17
sons bro you know I'm sayin you go to
the mall you come back with 15 sons like
air bags yeah dude so anything is
possible I think either one you got two
beautiful boys on the tree yeah yeah and
it looks like you guys are in the
Christmas spirit over there so people
are lazy though man
what he got with a 56% Realtree I love
that that's them some gangster [ __ ] oh
yeah
amen but it's not easy alright boys
let's wrap it up with some kinder sting
it alright getting to the gifts but
first I forgot we got gifts yeah this is
mark rice it's a boy big mark damn right
that's my [ __ ] bro
that's living Big Daddy oh yeah I love
that God that guy's beautiful I look
like Santa's little son you know like
it's like sweet little son that's nice
now whiskey son yeah son is always he's
like are you doing gifts well this and
he's like yeah oh yeah I'm having fun
I'll be at the mall here's a cool like
I'll say you know what the [ __ ] you
doing dude uh whiskey and eggnog I've
never had him it sounds that but listen
I don't even know if I was drinking
whiskey last year so maybe this year
give a little gingerbread cookie little
eggnog little Buffalo Trace or Blanton's
if I'm feeling fancy I love that down
that that eggnog though have you had it
recently mm-hmm [ __ ] so thick you throw
up dude it's thick there's so much sugar
in it praise God
hi dad you should keep buying me just
gallons one other kids yeah I think it's
[ __ ] now I just down it dude I couldn't
wait
ice-cold just chugging it oh yeah jicama
screamed oh oh I'll do a line of it bro
knock to the noggin Dawg I'll [ __ ]
douse myself up do not give the veins
bro that [ __ ] that brain beverage dawg
do you guys drink the eggnog your house
cat yeah sometimes eggnog in my coffee
oh really
cuz it's so thick so instead of cream
I'll use eggnog
it's good yeah eggnog is good man eggnog
it's almost like cuz if you cook it it's
like a pancake basically so you could
really just it's a thick substance it's
like having batter yeah you can only
have it you know around December if you
have you drinking eggnog on in March you
got [ __ ] progress you can't buy it
some things are only unleashed at a
certain time of year and that's you know
that's people that stock up so they have
it year around then [ __ ] yeah nog
trap houses you feel me bro only
December why you knocking so hard yeah I
know what you saying bro put that little
scissor bin that nas well the real lien
you are you a fan Depot no it's gross is
it you either hit you there nog question
you're not yeah Bad Santa
the Buffalo in there Nick rolling in
with some nog huh yeah she's disgusting
I'm very excited about
he doesn't need some too if you're upset
I'm excited if you like imma throw up I
can't I'll throw up for sure you will
well throw up then do this is a
Christmas episode you know what bro dude
anyone else you are not gay are you
drink two ounces of something that came
out of a chicken's butt you're not gonna
stay fully straight gay uh toast huh
how about a toast man somebody gift
one-year-anniversary bro I need homo
change its up what's up chin and on chin
don't look through Jenny okay where'd
this knob come from though target French
nah get that Whole Foods now again they
look at right Maz right now you know
pure as hell I was raised on that target
nog bro dude target nog
I'm on that King Soopers no warhead nog
broach you
boring ice-cold I like it what's a
little grainy I'll know what they have
in there a little grin was like a little
nutmeg or sand and that [ __ ]
but let's chairs boys King this thing
it's one year down baby down and a big
year ahead cheers brother you guys hate
you guys man cheers guys thank you
cheers so know what's gonna happen after
we drink this eggnog oh god it's good
[Music]
god Uman had a little bit of yolk at the
[Laughter]
milk at 7:00 what else we got I say you
know baby oh I'm sorry
I say nog baby I say yes to whiskey in
your eggnog I say no to straight-up
eggnog as an adult silver bells things
you can't do dude if you're doing Disney
Plus and bust with eggnog you got
problems
no yes sir you gotta get out the house
makes my nuts hard but I like it no one
watching Disney plus with eggnog for
hope yes I can
well you're doing it so it can't stop
you yes I can dude what's live alone I
don't feel good after eggnog cheap-ass a
goddamn cat ah very good huh it likes it
mm oh no Nick had this in his [ __ ]
bottle as a baby oh yeah these are the
Midwest of course he did that Wisconsin
man oh we playing cards we playing white
elephants on sounds racial huh it does I
don't know it's not about read the can
we read what the history of white
elephant is why it's a
school you know it's an Asian game yeah
it is Thailand Laos Cambodia Burma Wow
Sophie opens card first right okay
my stomach cramps well you got a tighten
up there I've had I've had all kind of
fluids bro wild fluid local bet you have
a playboy dude 2 to 5 you switch with
anyone you want if you're all six or
seven switch with the person to the
right if you roll an eight or nine
switch with the person to the left if
you're all a ten you open the goddamn
gift who has the dice okay okay oh gee
that open gift baby loses what um do we
know we don't know oh it's a secret okay
I keep telling people the blue bag and
don't make a face like it's from you
okay hey let's let's say once we're done
you got a guess whose gift that was to
do I'm gonna [ __ ] my pants that eggnog
not sitting well that's Bobby Lee he
always does that
oh this one is random thing that came in
from mark Kuechly or q cool from Kenosha
Wisconsin okay and it's from its to Theo
von podcasting we do not know what it is
so it's still white elephant kind of oh
just the boxes sorry oh my bed so I open
the gift now yeah all right
you didn't really think this one that
guy did you yes I did thank you mark
that's cool from Kenosha not a different
page from the Kenosha Belles
oh wow a couple things in here we got
that Ridge wallet ooh
we got this okay like a trophy yeah it's
kind of like your dad Tom Brady dude
look at it
it's not Tom Brady I'd be like more of a
Kurt cousins or plastic Tom Brady we got
some trolley candies
[Music]
that's Nick that's Nick oh my god
apparently Nick won some sort of
competition Wow
dang it is him dang I mean I know
dang Nick that's pretty cool I got that
you make this Nick got that 3d Nick oh
and these zoom AC head adapters man and
these are he's anything whirring it's
shooting yes and have to pretend oh damn
this is a pretty dope yeah a Nick your
een that's pretty awesome row Nick you
doing the dak Prescott - Oh Nick you
sure you want to give these to your
girlfriend how many of here's the
question is how many up must he have if
he's willing to give a couple away just
a question thank you very much I love my
gift hey there's nothing but someone
pretending that they like their gift
them not that you're doing that but it's
the best you ready big bro
I'm ready man Oh in this candy in here -
trolley candies trollee sour not my face
bright crawlers not my faves yeah I
can't have that much sugar but I do love
it though my stomach is there's a
[ __ ] bebop and rocksteady going on my
stomach right now but dog I'll be
alright though if you get the Master
Splinter's that's when you're not doing
well yeah okay yeah you get that
Michelangelo in my pants uh Jack Jack
it's a ten right eject yeah ten oh damn
you guys just making up [ __ ] now oh yeah
throw it against the wall open it up
dude it's nice it's a nice feeling
opening gifts oh that's a dope little
gift oh wow what is that snoop ox tan
socks to sob
hmm Morgan Freeman with a bandana but
that shit's done they said it would take
on my hands I cannot use yeah yeah
really I guess I wear these socks
I guess I'll feel comfortable wearing
these on stage no what sign come on man
sighs yeah I guess I feel comfortable
enough to wear black faces black feet I
didn't have no Michael Buble so come on
bro yeah hey even though ours is open
you can still steal our gifts huh yeah
yeah yeah yeah I suck you know Sonia
this ace switch with the person to the
right god damn it all right switch to
the person to your right be me that's
Derek you're a tree Jenna trade no
tariff yet you got to know what's going
on you got a six which to the person on
your right who I hope you keep tag that
yeah so we go to them right
make the right turn yeah open I got that
Tim I already open okay please give me a
sort of six seven four switch with
anyone I'll take your gift Nick take
these take these black power
really yeah beautiful weird oh man
switch off anyway
also what you're Brendon I knew it in
this is a nice-looking gift feel like
it's a pie in there it was a fire you
would know in your heart if it was you
right dude you really wishin like I
intuition switch with anyone
yeah I'll take chance gift yang I know
what's the Heisman Trophy of Nick yeah
you two of them dude's crazy that's
pretty cool it stands you
yeah I just went hey when's this end oh
wow
Derek I'm them socks up girl bro from
the show
dang Nick could have had his trophy back
but didn't want it huh feel sis I got a
sick person I you're right sweetie
Nick you know Nick hey Nick here's your
3d printer chips chips huh you don't
don't don't be sneaky ready big bro yeah
King open open it Wow
biggest to open them all I really
appreciate everyone put the effort into
wrapping this - I like the Ralphs bag is
really nice touch Allah brings you back
to my childhood thank you guys I love
Ralphs
- oh wow a signed that star for Lion
King that's scar from liking is it
really yes
it's a signed scarf from liking Easter
ah Alba Oh
Idris Elba Easter algebra who is
assigned by tho from him no uh Wow it
looks like says and is it but it looks
like it's signed by Ben Roethlisberger
does that have a certificate of
authenticity with it or is it just I
don't see how anybody could sign that
not positive it's him yeah you got to
check the Beckett okay can't who's up oh
wow
here we go no this one's not open and
brynn is not open hey do I have to throw
is that what it is
little rice cooker that's gin he does
it's like I got intuition for pies you
got intuition for rice oh yeah the rice
has the most racist yeah but you see
sometimes look if your first one goes
out you got three switch with anyone
I'll take that big brown I did have that
gift in mind when I got when I bought it
I was thinking dirt hopefully Derrick
gets that gift
silly sidewalk Jim Brennan is looking at
these gifts first day off on the dog
dude I get the [ __ ] ball good damn
chill kids going for that gift wrong bag
bro it's front it's a tradition jeez I
wonder everything's ending up right
where it's supposed to be yeah hey I
guess you already open oh we just got
the Oh laughs dude
open it up dan yeah just me like Oh home
sweet home dude advanced care 33% more
electrolytes and this one replaces and
fluids and zinc but damn you know that
was from Theo I know this whole world
dude oh wow Nick oh I kind of want this
now that's fine how they getting back in
there okay exactly like Nick this is
hopper from stranger things I love
hopper bod wow that's great that's a
fantastic gift God mics for switch with
anyone I'll switch with you
will you yeah you take the berry
Pedialyte yeah take that oh nice good
way to prove I'm not racist by having
this on my desk
hmm oh just one of my many cultural
friends to 7:00 right baby yeah it's
mostly I when I bought that gift I was
thinking of Derrick now that's the
Lord's work at that's the L baby that's
the Lord take those black socks you Jim
be careful where them socks now yep big
deal what is it it is a nice switch with
person on the Left [ __ ]
oh yeah hey bud sorry to see you go but
I hope to see you soon yeah ace open
your open already open opening them up
you got it I got it open them up see
what she is now make sure you use this
thing I got you in mind okay bus mr.
bust himself come on
got that bus lamp baby ah ha ha ha that
bus layout
yeah I need you to make deposits in that
thing bro we can't have him jerk-off
into a lamp there we're gonna go to jail
yeah that's fire dude beautiful man does
it say what kind of fluids are liquid
they can hold in their die cuz honestly
man if you do want to try it it it's
totally up to you it doesn't have
anything to do with employment but it is
totally up to you we're not liable but
if you do wanna stick your dick inside
not inside of it dude dude from above
the rim no he's black he can do it from
above the rim but it's not like us where
we have to just lay up near the edge of
it the top and whatever happens after
you open that that's on you D we don't
insurance no really on the DL if you
want to see how that kind of works out
because man if we came out with a real
bus lamp or somebody could accurately
hold their own ejaculate in their
apartment the real sea monkeys yeah dude
we'd be [ __ ] living large man praise
God brother so that's kind of our test
pilot business bro yeah they branded us
Seabiscuit was a [ __ ] appetizer dude
[Laughter]
we're at this I can restaurant by the
ocean Jesus hey who brought did you
bring this D yeah who did you sign to
buy though that's a forgery I told Joe
oh yeah I thought it was a little fishy
I don't know authenticity man ha poor
dog there's Nick right databar bro nick
is always in my life cat got the rice
maker chain from chin chin what you end
up with the socks
that's dope then make that the black
socks and feel you got the hopper bond
yeah I got the scarf autograph I think
we did it make its Merry Christmas man
great Christmas candy
Merry Christmas amen brother
god bless man you get home to the family
for Christmas and then this weekend I'm
in Oklahoma
then Tulsa oh nice hard rock casino in
Tulsa to shows nice and OKC one show
Tulsa you got that New Year's Eve to son
I thought a lot of work you know bro
yeah like Santa to show you AR I'm like
Santa to shows New Year's Eve ice house
Pasadena be shopping friends live dude I
don't know this egg not sitting well so
no promises but as of now I'll be there
dude I'll make a dang omelet with this
stuff this stuff beautiful dude I love
eggnog dude makes me feel like a human
man well I'd like to say is um oh I
don't know where I'll be coming up I'll
be in a Red Bank New Jersey and I'll be
in Oxon Hill Maryland and I'll be in
Manchester London Oslo Stockholm you
going on tour right yeah I'm going to
Europe let's let the fans know we're
gonna take a little break yeah
we're gonna take a little break we're
gonna take a couple weeks off yep
so deals in Europe and I got some stuff
going on where we're gonna the show will
be back in middle January yeah mid mid
January we'll be back yep so just stay
tuned not be Holidays to everybody and
um thank you thank you guys you be happy
holidays thank you brah yeah jingle bell
jingle bell
kicking this thing what up yeah it's
lasik Mic Check one two yeah yeah okay
Theo you are here rockin bolus like you
don't whip in LA in the Taurus you were
Brendan never bore us both the you I
love you feel looking like a farmer
written looking like he in the TV show
Arthur there what it do wanna saw you in
my town bro can't city loves you looking
like a dim Fat Albert yeah you my girl
out of seven told you yet I've been
waiting for the perfect time as perfect
as it gets that was us just waiting for
chin to get a date King in the sting
will thinking rabies coming to your town
just to spread some scabies holla holla
Brenda now to Colorado was a brawl in
our talk icky and singing in the momma
buzz-buzz